hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast live in targeted therapies for
cancer and autoimmune diseases in Brenda
Kelly kim of lab roots and helping a
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by ladders and
sponsored by roche molecular diagnostics
headquartered in Pleasanton California
roche molecular diagnostics is a
business area of roche diagnostics that
develops manufactures and supplies and
wide array of innovative medical
diagnostic products services tests
platforms and technologies with its
broad portfolio of oncology neurology
microbiology blood screening tests on
these clients and researchers physicians
patients hospitals laboratories and
blood banks around the world business
was founded in the early 1990s fallen in
the eye position for the revolutionary
Nobel Prize winning polymerase chain
reaction technology PCR quickly
replicates a specific fragment of DNA or
RNA two quantities sufficient for
accurate laboratory analysis for more
information please visit life sciences
Roche calm live a few announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be an interactive and we encourage
you to ask questions during the event
you can submit questions like typing
them in the Q&A box which can be found
by clicking in green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window so
try to get to as many of your questions
as we can you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any problems hearing
or seeing this presentation properly
please let us know by clicking on the
support button the top right of your
presentation window or submit the
problem for the green Q&A button or left
this presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain your credits please click
on the get your free cme c ii credits
button located in the lower
of your screen this will take you to a
page first in all of our speakers and
presentations please select the CD CM e
button under the presentation and follow
the instructions to claim your
certificate will now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Philip 12 dr. Philip
Lahm is the director of the purdue
university center for drug discovery and
the ralphs equally distinguished
professor of chemistry dr. Lowe has
spent over thirty nine years exploring
novel methods the drug targeting and
characterizing structure function and
pathologies of the roof recite membrane
has published more than 350 scientific
articles and has more than 50 US patents
pending when more information about dr.
lobe please click on his name to see his
background and experience will now turn
it over to dr. Lowe for his presentation
autoimmune diseases seeing you and we
take a unique approach to trying to
achieve the two major objectives that
are prescribed by the FDA for any new
drug new drugs need to be both safe and
also effective and the standard method
for trying to achieve both safety and
efficacy in a drug is to try to build
both properties into the same molecule
this is often very difficult as when one
optimizes the specificity of a drug for
a particular target or pathway one must
at the same time change the potency of
the drug and sometimes it's very
difficult to build both high potency and
high specificity into the same molecule
our approach is to build the safety and
the specificity into two different parts
of the molecule and that's shown on this
slide here where we use a targeting
ligand that
it is marked here in yellow and we'll
talk about a number of these that are
capable of carrying attached cargoes
either to cancer cells or sites of
inflammation and autoimmune disease or
infectious diseases and also we then
build a second part the potency up into
the payload shown in the upper left-hand
corner there the payload then can be a
therapeutic agent for treatment of a
disease it can be an imaging agent for
monitoring progress to therapy for
identifying patients for aid in surgery
is all described in just a moment and
then as part of the same conjugate we
also use a spacer linker connecting the
targeting ligand to the payload and this
spacer linker can be used to optimize
the PK the PD of the drug to also build
in multiple drugs into the same
conjugate and exploit other
opportunities similar to this I'm going
to begin by using our first targeting
ligand that we developed folic acid as
an example and take you through a few of
the interesting applications of this
both in delivering therapeutic and
imaging agents folic acid as you can see
here is taken into cells by three
different routes on the left-hand side
we find that there are two transporters
of carry in the vitamin one is the
reduced folate carrier the reduced
folate carrier is found in virtually all
cells of the body another is a proton
coupled folate transporter it is also
found in virtually all cells of the body
these have lower affinity for the
vitamin in the neighborhood of ten to
the minus fifth moulder a third pathway
for uptake of this vitamin is a foaling
receptor this receptor is very rarely
expressed as I'll show in
the next slide and this this expression
is primarily limited to cells that want
to take up the vitamin when there's very
little vitamin available as a
consequence the binding constant as a
neighbor is in the neighborhood of ten
to the minus tenth molar now the
important application of this
information for the seminar today is
that the reduced volley carrier and
proton co folate transporters are found
throughout the body in all normal cells
and the receptors primarily found on
malignant cells and also activated
macrophages and I'll describe these the
applications of this unique expression
pattern in a moment this a slide if I
don't see the video running its supposed
to show receptor-mediated endocytosis of
the of the of appellate linked rhodamine
conjugate where the arrow points if the
movie were operative it would show
endocytosis of a pole a rhodamine
conjugate as it in vanets of the cell
surface and enters the cell cancer cells
take in that have Foley receptors are
taking in folate conjugates x receptor
mediated endocytosis very rapidly the
internalization process takes just a few
minutes and the receptor eventually
recycles back to the cell surface for
more vitamin folate conjugates entered
by the same pathway activated
macrophages that also express Foley
receptors actually Reese I take the
conjugates in also very rapidly but the
recycling rate is much faster only a few
minutes is require required before the
receptor returns to the cell surface
following entry into the cell the Foley
conjugates traffic through a variety of
endosomes and these endosomes are
generally reducing
nature and so disulfide bonds built into
the drug molecules as you can see the
the drug mimic up above contains a
disulfide bond these disulfide bonds are
reduced are cleaved upon entry into the
cells but they're generally quite stable
during circulation and because our
collate conjugates reach their sites of
action in tumors or in inflamed tissues
within five minutes and saturate the
receptors within the same amount of time
the disulfide bond turns out to be
sufficiently stable in circulation that
we don't see much drug release but
following endocytosis into the target
cell the reducing environment releases
the drug you can see in this particular
image the red spots in the center show
that the released rhodamine that's
connected to folate by the disulfide
bond and is trapped in endosomes if this
rhodamine were remembering permeable it
would diffuse out of these endosomes and
enter the cell where are fully receptor
is accessible to parentally administered
folate conjugates turns out at cancer a
number of cancer tissues but not all
cancer tissues over expressive Foley
receptor is fine primarily found in
cancers of the ovary lung breast kidney
endometrial colon and hematopoietic
answers as I mentioned earlier also
activated macrophages have accessible
for live receptors activated monocytes
do also but curiously resting or classic
macrophages and monocytes do not express
the folate receptor so this receptor is
uniquely found on only the inflamed
subpopulation of these my locks it
excels then finally as will point out in
a moment the poet receptor is expressed
and accessible on the apical surface of
the proximal tubules cells of the kidney
and I won't go into this any further but
I will mention at this point that we
have tested a number of very toxic
folate link drugs in both preclinical
and in human clinical trials and we do
not find that any of them cause any
toxicity to the kidneys and the reason
why it emerged in a study that we did a
few years ago where we followed the
itinerary of these Foley conjugates in
kidneys and live mice and we find that
although the receptor mediates uptake of
the folate conjugate by the kidney it
also mediates transcytosis of the full a
conjugate across a kidney where it's
released back into the bloodstream so it
turns out to really be a salvaged
receptor to keep the patient from going
full a division so it captures the
folate in the urine and puts it back in
the bloodstream to keep you from losing
the vitamin that you need as a
consequence the kidney doesn't retain it
nor is it nor is it damaged by poli
conjugates this bar graph shows the
expression level is these are some of
our latest data on fully receptor in
different cancers you can see that
ovarian cancer over eighty eight percent
of ovarian cancers express the folate
receptor about eighty percent of
non-small-cell lung cancers maybe
three-quarters of kidney cancers large
number of endometrial colorectal and
breast but then at the same time you'll
notice that there are quite a number of
very important cancers like brain
cancers prostate cancers pancreatic
cancers and so forth that do not express
significant levels of fully receptor and
because of that it's we'll talk about in
a moment it is important to be able to
design targeting ligands that will carry
attached therapeutic and imaging agents
to these other cancers also and we have
undertaken this task
addition to the using pulling this light
here shows the emek the distribution of
foley receptors by imaging and on the
left hand side is a healthy patient in
this healthy patient you can see in the
whole body scan uptake only in the
kidneys and if you remember a moment ago
I told you there were three sites where
fully receptors were overexpressed one
was in cancer tissues well this help the
individual doesn't have cancer so we
wouldn't see any update there a second
was in activated macrophages enacted
activated monocytes but not in resting
in Matta fighting cells of any sort and
so because there's no inflammation in
this individual we don't see update at
any other sites associated with
inflammation and then finally we had
mentioned that there was uptake in the
there were four late receptors on the
apical surfaces of the proximal tubules
cells and that leads to uptake in the
kidneys and as I said that will
eventually disappear as it moves the
quality folate conjugate or the vitamin
back into the bloodstream on the right
hand side of this paired image you'll
see a patient with stage three ovarian
cancer you can see even with malignant
disease throughout the peritoneal cavity
over on the right and the insert you see
the breast cancer metastasized to the
brain look below that you'll see a
primary brain tuner and so forth so in
patients that don't have cancer or
inflammatory disease you see just the
kidneys and other patients you'll see
whatever either the inflamed
inflammatory disease or the malignant
disease so this imaging we think is very
important as you'll see in this cartoon
I incorrect diagnosis of the real
problem can lead to an incorrect therapy
for that problem here the therapy that's
being prescribed as a mild sedative for
anxiety and vicodin for the back pain
and obviously that's not the solution to
the problem so a better diagnostics can
significantly assist in
better than trip and designing better
therapies one of the Diagnostics that we
have designed is the use of these
targeting ligands to deliver attached
fluorescent light bulbs very selectively
to tumor tissues and this allows us to
light up tumors with a bright
fluorescent signal and using a
fluorescent my present camera this can
enable the surgeon to locate and resect
malignant disease much more efficiently
and accurately than was previously
possible we can also use this same
structure for delivery of photodynamic
therapy agents and a few other
applications this can be used as I
mentioned above went with any targeting
ligand and I'll give you a few examples
of this now in the next few slides this
particular movie here actually is a
video of the provided by go van damme
and Vasilisa Zia's Christo's at the
university of groningen in munich and
what it shows is the first as far as we
know page surgery performed on this
planet using a tumor targeted
fluorescent dye and in this case the
patient was injected about two hours
before surgery with folate linked to
flourishing that's shown on the left is
not very bright there and and the polite
flourishing of course / fuses throughout
the body and is captured by cancer cells
at this point in the surgery the
surgeons dr. bad Dan believes he's
removed most of it virtually all of the
cancer that he can see with the naked
eye and now you can see looking at the
omentum of this cancer patient they're
looking around to see if there's any
additional disease and they can't fight
it until they turn on the fluorescent
lamp here they see all these fluorescent
lesions but at this point in the surgery
they don't know if these fluorescent
spots are indeed malignant or not and so
dr. Van Dam has the technician take
these with her forceps and run to the
pathologist next door who then looks and
evaluates whether
those fluorescent lesions are indeed
malignant or not and it turned out from
these surgeries and subsequent ones
performed by this group in Leiden excuse
me in greeting and that essentially all
of the fluorescent lesions were
malignant and they found as you can see
at the bottom of this slide and with the
citation where the data are published
that they were able to remove
approximately five times more malignant
lesions with the aid of fluorescence
than by standard methods in following a
group of I think eight surgeries this
next slide shows that in fact even very
small lesions can be revealed by this
method if the University of Leiden
Medical Center dr. bar Meyer and tumors
and hoops tins have been doing similar
work and you can see in this stain the
folate receptor positive tumor cells in
this section and you'll notice over on
the right-hand side where the
fluorescent folate fluorescein
accumulated following intravenous
injection in in the arm even though this
comes from an ovarian cancer patient and
the lesions obviously from the
peritoneal cavity and you'll see that
every spot seen in the center panel is
fluorescent in the right-hand panel
suggesting even in that lesion up in the
upper left-hand corner of the panel
there are only about four or five cells
there that even very few cells can be
targeted and illuminated by this method
will go on to the next slide here and
these data were provided by dr. sunil
singh hall at the University of
Pennsylvania who has done quite a number
of these surgeries on lung cancer
patients and you can see on the
left-hand side the image that is
visualized by the surgeon if you turn on
the fluorescent lamp you see the one on
the right hand side the major lesion
there in the center that's fluorescent
was was in fact
seen in the CT scan the smaller one on
the lower right was not and of course
this changes the whole diagnosis staging
and so forth of the patient and it also
alters the surgery of course this allows
the surgeon to remove these extra
lesions that were not seen and would not
have been seen without fluorescence more
recently because flora seen is not
visible very for more than a half a
millimeter in tissue we've gone and made
similar fully targeted near-infrared
dyes that are fluorescent in the near
infrared range where light is more
permeable or penetrating to tissue and
the structure shown here on the left on
the right comparison of the green versus
the red curve shows that the the full
light near-infrared died binds with the
same affinity as free folic acids that
we haven't lost any and the affinity for
folate receptors on cancer cells and
here is a surgery that was performed by
the same group at the University of
Leiden University Medical Center and
that the fluorescence is very diffuse
there as you can see it looks very
spread out and as a consequence that
indicated that there may be a
fluorescent lesion deep in the tissue
and that the light is being scattered as
it is as it comes out of the tissue and
eventually of course digging down they
found this fluorescent lesion which
turned out to be malignant which would
have never been seen by any other method
this next image just shows the
comparison on the lower right with seen
by a surgeon using all of today's
standard methods versus the image on the
upper left which is an image revealing
what the surgeon sees with these new
tutor targeted fluorescent dyes that are
accumulate only in malignant tissue and
reveal wherever malignant disease is
located you can see when they see that
fluorescent signal then they can go in
and feel it with their finger to see if
it
if it demonstrates the altered tech tile
sensations that are associated with a
more rigid tumor and as you can see then
if they are they feel comfortable about
it they can go ahead and pull it out and
reset and this of course turned out to
be cancer we have a lot of other movies
like this but I'll just jump to a few of
the bottom lines and that is very small
lymph nodes as you can see in the upper
right and and lower right a can be
revealed even when they're buried using
these near-infrared dies and we believe
in the long term this can save a lot of
lives by allowing the surgeon to find
all of the most of the malignant disease
that may have otherwise been missed
moving on we recognizing that this is a
new technology that could revolutionize
surgery in the future by allowing all
malignant disease to be quickly located
and resected we have gone on and linked
our near infrared die up to a number of
other targeting ligands in this
particular animal model we made a
targeting ligand for prostate specific
membrane antigen this will allow imaging
prostate cancer we have another one that
targets cholecystokinin to receptor this
images and GI tract cancers we've got
still a another one that images neuro
kind and one receptor is targets a
number of neuroendocrine tumors I could
go on and on and on but we have quite a
few we're trying to select the right
collection of these to put into a
cocktail that we believe will be
effective for imaging virtually all
cancers in addition to helping the
search and find cancer tissue we've also
undertaken that help the surgeon avoid
accidentally cutting important healthy
tissues in this particular image I
challenge you to
locate the the ureter and you can see
what looks like a number of different
tubes on the left going up the left-hand
side and a little bit more to the right
going straight up and down and even more
than that but if you really want to know
you can use a ureter targeted die and
when you look you see the ureters
actually way over on the right and this
is important because there are over a
half a million surgeries for
endometriosis a year in the United
States and a clipping the ureter can
account can occur it's not uncommon
during those surgeries also during colon
cancer surgeries there's a often
mistakenly clipped because it's very
very hard to see another another
potential application of this of course
targeting nerves and you know avoidance
of cutting nerves can be very important
in a number of surgeries for example in
prostate cancer surgery the nerve that
innervates the prostate gland is cut
then the patient is often incontinent
and or impotent and that's that's
important to avoid so this slide just
lists a number of the possible uses of
this these tumor targeted fluorescent
dyes with that we can use them to
quantitate circulating tumor cells we
can localize and resect what the
surgeons can localize and resect more
malignant disease as I showed you
elimination of positive margins on the
tumors is very important so that there's
no residual disease left in the patient
we commit these tools can also be used
for pre-surgical endoscopic diagnosis of
the stage of the cancer and assessing
whether surgery is even and even called
for in particular cases if it's if the
cancer spread widely then often the
surgeon will decide not to operate but
just turn the patient over before
chemotherapy
assessment of disease recurrence it's
for example in ovarian cancer a patient
goes through surgery is then placed on
chemotherapy and shortly afterwards then
the patient is placed on chemotherapy
and then there's a waiting period and if
recurrence does occur it's only seen
usually about 13 months later if there
were a way of assessing that recurrence
much earlier i think a lot more lives
could be saved and then of course as I
mentioned earlier identification of
metastatic lymph nodes is important and
avoiding damage to healthy tissues so
there's a lot of potential for this
let's talk a little bit about killing
tumors by targeting them with the same
targeting ligands I just mentioned I'll
give one example on this this is the
structure of a direct identified a
company that I found it has taken into
clinical trials it's in phase three and
you can see here the structure involves
on the Left folic acid in black link the
spacer and blue to a cleavable bond that
title but I spoke about earlier in green
and then the warhead is this vinca
alkaloid that is about a thousand times
more potent and vinblastine it's a
modified version of that it was taken
into animal studies and we can see that
regardless of how large the tuners are
even update hundred cubic millimeters as
soon as they're treated the tumors
disappeared the real question was though
with this very potent drug which was
very toxic and dropped immediately from
clinical trials due to toxicity in its
non-targeted form that is when it was
just administered without a targeting
like in the real question that we wanted
to answer immediately was what happens
when we targeted to be still suffer from
this intolerable toxicity and you can
see after the first 100 patients were
examined with this folic targeted
version there were absolutely no great
for toxicities there were very few great
three toxicities and those are limited
to constipation and the associated
domino pain which can could be treated
with an over-the-counter laxative this
would visit these are the results of the
study with just a single agent
administered by itself but anyway the
prediction that targeting the drug would
reduce off-target toxicity was fulfilled
and demonstrated in this study just to
illustrate this further we saw known you
absolutely zero neutropenia no bone
marrow suppression even though the naked
drugs or something very similar to it
shows that and virtually half of the
patients the drugs also at the bullets
also used to select patients in this top
example of a CT scan on the left and
then a fully targeted imaging agent
let's a technician based imaging agent
linked to folic acid you can see to the
two lesions very clearly and in that
case you had this would indicate that
the malignant lesions have Foley
receptors and so if we can target a
fully linked imaging agent we should be
able to target apple it mayn't
therapeutic agent and we go ahead and
treat that patient in this example below
the malignant lesion circled in yellow
do not show up in the folate scan in the
middle and so the conclusion there is
not the tree and whip followed through
with this and this just shows what
happens in and why this pre selection of
patients with the imaging agent is so
important here is a study with our that
folate vinca alkaloid only as a single
agent no accompanying cytotoxic drug and
we just looked at at the survival of
patients where a hundred percent of the
lesions that's the top a kaplan-meier
curve where a hundred percent of the
lesions express the folate receptor and
when they're treated with a folate
receptor targeted drug they do very well
in the middle kaplan-meier plot there
somewhere between ten and ninety percent
of the lesions in the patients we're
call it receptor positive and they did
not do as well and then in patients
where none of the lesions are fully
receptor positive they did even even
worse this just
demonstrates the importance of using an
imaging agent for selecting patients for
therapy this is also confirmed in
studies of non solum small cell lung
cancer patients again those with higher
percentages of folate receptor
expression did much better in both
overall survival and progression-free
survival whoops um I don't know what
happened there I'm then I need some help
I I not sure what happened let me see
okay it looks like i have control over
things again although i can't see a lot
of what i used to see these are data on
a non small cell lung cancer patients
using the same drug where we're
comparing the standard of care which is
docetaxel alone versus docetaxel plus
the folate targeted vinca alkaloid
called ec145 and you can see just from
the kaplan-meier curve that the
combination therapy that led to a median
overall survival of 12.5 months whereas
the standard of care docetaxel led only
to six point six months more recently we
have replaced the folate targeted vinca
alkaloid with a fully targeted to hbu
licen and looking at these four graphs
here the fully targeted tibu licen be is
in blue and you can see that in all of
these different tumor xenograft models
the folate targeted tibu lyzen is much
more potent than the folate targeted
vinca alkaloid and actually performs
better for two reasons number one it's
fundamentally much more potent as a
basic drug and number two as you can see
here on the right in tumor cells are in
tumor xenografts that
been selected for their high expression
of p-glycoprotein or drug resistant
pumps the fully targeted to beuliss and
as a much poorer substrate of these
pumps than many other drugs and so it's
resistant to these e flex pumps and so
that in addition to its higher potency
it's reduced susceptibility to eat
Bloods pumping makes it a better drug
this is now in Phase one clinical trials
and it's just in the dose escalation
stage what about fol- cancers on this is
the crystal structure of prostate
specific membrane antigen when this
crystal structure came out we
immediately designed a small molecule to
feel fit into the bottom of that clock
at the UC at pockets about 20 angstroms
Steve it makes great raw material for
structure-based drug design this is a
cutaway view of that pocket and on the
left-hand side you can see the drug
sitting deep in the pocket and there's
there's a spacer we have some additions
on to that space or to improve overall
affinity and then on the right you can
see the therapeutic warhead or imaging
agent and we have used this to image
cancer patients here is a comparison of
the same patient at the same time
scanned with a bone scan on actually
stuck consecutively with a bone scan on
the right the bone scan is designed to
pick up raw bone where the cancer which
often metastasizes to the bone has eaten
through and exposed raw hydroxyapatite
and you can see late lesions in the
upper left hand shoulder there and in
the ribs and so forth on the left hand
side is the image with the PSM a
targeted imaging agent that we designed
you can see the same lesions that you
see on the right but many additional
lesions and these additional lesions are
due to malignant disease that has not
yet eaten through and exposed the raw
hydroxyapatite this turns out to be very
important especially in cases
as you see right here where you can see
the prostate gland which is malignant
that shone pointed at by the arrows
there but also a metastatic lymph node
which would never be revealed by the
bone scan because there's no bone there
and so by being able to image soft
malignant tissue this is very important
of course we can use this also to
deliver therapeutic drugs this structure
shows the structure of folate excuse me
this dupas we call it targeted to hbu
lies in conjugate and down below are the
data on tumor growth in animal models
the green curve shows that when we dos
these animals after their tumors reach
roughly 400 cubic millimeters they
immediately disappear this dupa
conjugate is also in phase 1 clinical
trials right now submit color on the
graduate student in my lab designed this
we have tart as I mentioned earlier
targeting targeting lying in the targets
call a sista kind of two receptor these
are the cancers that's can over express
it you can see here the binding constant
and its competition and the image there
shows the uptake very selectively in the
tumor in this slide we can see the tarc
the structure of the therapeutic
conjugate of the same targeting ligand
this also leads to a good tumor control
without any weight loss as you can look
at the weight loss curve on the right
and the tender control is on the left on
the neuro plane and one receptor ligands
also been used for therapeutic
applications so this is an imaging agent
on the left on the right is competition
and when we add competitive ligand to
block receptors we see no uptake in the
tumor the structure of the targeted
therapeutic agent which is a tubulin
conjugate is shown on the top there and
again we get good tumor control
without any weight loss with this
conjugate we have a number of other
ligands under development for tumor
targeting in our lab and this just shows
a list of some of the tumors that we
have ligands for that we're developing
right now for clinical translation um I
just spend just a couple of seconds on
our use of these other targeting ligands
for addressing infectious diseases the
same general concept of using a
targeting ligand to deliver and attached
imaging or therapeutic agent
specifically to sites of infection is
also valid this is an image of some mice
where we placed some h1n1 virus three
microliters on the nose of the mouse and
then waited three days on the left and
then injected in the tail vein a ligand
that targets the virus infected cells on
the right is a control mouse injected
with the same imaging agent and it's a
technetium 99 imaging agent and you can
see that we get targeting to the
infected cells in the lung um more
recently we've been working on a drug
for treating malaria we're actually
starting clinical trials on this the
anti-malarial agent blocks the egress or
the escape of the malaria parasite from
the red blood cell by inhibiting a red
blood cell ensign that the parasite pets
has to activate in order to get out of
the cell and by blocking this red cell
enzyme rather than targeting a
plasmodium falciparum enzyme we believe
that we can prevent any mutation
generated resistance because the
parasite can't mutate the human genome
and it relies on this enzyme to get out
and so by blocking at weak and rapid
we're starting clinical trials with done
preclinical work and be
we're starting clinical trials very soon
both Vietnam and Africa plainly for the
last few moments of my talk would like
to just address the application of this
technology for treating autoimmune and
inflammatory diseases briefly but while
imaging cancer patients with our folic
targeted radio imaging agent EC 20 and
with image probably over a thousand of
these patients by now we noticed in a
few of them some uptake of the folate
targeted drug in the knee or in a
shoulder and we knew that a patient does
not get cancer the knee very often so we
wondered what might be happening here to
make a long story short we obtained some
synovial fluid from one of these
patients and look to see what cells in
the synovial fluid might have fully
receptors and we found that activated
macrophages expressed folic receptors
further pursuit of this research area
revealed that resting macrophages do not
express folate receptors nor do t cells
B cells mast cells eosinophils basophils
and so on and so forth it's a reuni
about of the very activated subset of
monocytes and macrophages and because
these are found in virtually all
malignant all excuse me all inflammatory
and autoimmune diseases this gave us a
wonderful agent for targeting
inflammatory and autoimmune disease I'll
just show you a few stage using a
monoclonal antibody to folate receptor
beta it's a beta isoform and these are
human tissues these data were obtained
at Mayo Clinic here on rheumatoid
arthritis the brown stain shows the
expression of folate receptor on these
activated macrophages that that was a
the previous slide with rheumatoid
arthritis is this ulcerative colitis you
can see a lot of brown spots those are
collections of macrophages this is
scleroderma again it's characterized by
accumulation of folate receptor beta
pause
macrophages idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis this isn't characterized by
accumulation of these anti inflammatory
or alternatively activated macrophages
but still they have fully receptors
whereas resting macrophages do not Steve
all over at NYU at the time is right now
at novartis stains psoriatic tissue for
us in the upper right hand corner you
see the green spots revealed where
macrophages are located in the psoriatic
lesions the upper left you can see the
stain for foley receptor beta virtually
a hundred percent of the macro pages
they're in and the inflamed tissue is
expressed foley receptors on the lower
left you see where cells are located and
you can see based on the hurks die which
state nuclei and you can see again the
blue spots in the upper left hand corner
revealed that their skin cells there but
the skin that part of the skin is normal
it's not sorry attic so it doesn't have
any macrophages or any bullet receptors
so imaging of an autoimmune disease is
we can also use the imaging agent for
those these are images of rheumatoid
arthritis hands these were done at Mayo
Clinic by Eric Madison here Virginia
Carlos at Duke University look at
osteolytic joints and they were we they
reveal exactly the sites where active
inflammation is occurring here is in
sjögren's syndrome we can we can see
atherosclerosis this would published on
this a number of times and we can see a
ischemic tissue where the macrophages
accumulate after the escambia in this
case is a scheming colitis just to make
a long story short with look at all of
these diseases on this list and all of
them are characterized by a significant
accumulation of these activated folic
receptor-positive macrophages this is a
lot this allows for both imaging and
treatment of these diseases let me just
talk about a therapy for them briefly
and we've looked at the use of a full
eight targeted em and after and Emin
operands
a precursor of methotrexate it's more
potent than methotrexate by quite a bit
but it's also more toxic and so we
selected it because we don't worry about
the toxicity because we have control
over where it goes and by targeting it
to the activated macrophages we don't
have to worry about the toxicity here we
see ec semi c 7 46 which is the poli
depa m and offering conjugate it leads
to a significant control of the
rheumatoid arthritis in this adjuvant
induced arthritis model and rats and if
we block the receptor where the line
showing ec 7 46 plus competitor is where
we add an excess of folic acid to block
the receptor we see no efficacy so it
really is receptor-mediated on the right
is a comparison with methotrexate it's
not as good as the target and a man
doctrine competition doesn't work very
well either and we can also look at
experimental auto-immune uveitis this is
an inflammation in the eye and just to
make a long story short the result is to
say in these are data from june loose
group at endo site and she can she sees
at 746 prevents the uveitis and you can
block that therapeutic benefit by adding
excess folic acid and the histology will
demonstrate that on the left we've also
looked at a model of multiple sclerosis
it's called experimental autoimmune
encephalomyelitis in this case the
animal is vaccinated against myelin
basic protein and they develop an immune
response to their the brain and these
animals become immobilized they can't
move their legs and so forth and if you
treat them with the folate targeted a
man up and they
can run around the cage this again shows
some data on that that's the same data
as you've seen before so I won't repeat
it and finally experimental pull a
targeted therapy for experimental
inflammatory bowel disease this is a
these studies were done in Aisle 10
knockout mice they developed a
ulcerative colitis as seen in the images
there on the left and this colitis can
be greatly prevented by in this genetic
model by just treatment with the PC 746
the Foley targeted am an option my final
topic I'd like to bring up I think it's
one that is very important for drug
companies interested in conducting a
clinical trial for any one of the
mentioned autoimmune or inflammatory
diseases we've found that using a fully
targeted imaging agent we can actually
predict the outcome of any therapy long
before the clinical manifestations show
themselves and this is an example here
in this slide we have induced rheumatoid
arthritis collagen-induced arthritis in
these mice and three days after
induction of the arthritis we imaged
with the bully targeted imaging agent
and the animal treated with methotrexate
on the Left shows know what taken there
in there inflamed feet to the arthritic
feet the animal treated with
dexamethasone on the right shows know
what take of the folate targeted imaging
agent the animal in the center that
wasn't treated shows significant uptake
that's just due to the accumulation of
activated macrophages if you look on
this slide in the upper left-hand corner
the on a clinical score at this time and
down below the plot thickness score at
that time shows absolutely no difference
between the treated and untreated
animals that is physically looking at
at swelling of the paw redness and all
of the different parameters associated
with scoring the rheumatoid arthritis
they're indistinguishable but if you
follow those same animals later on and
by day 11 there are enormous differences
between them yet that was not visible at
83 when the imaging agent revealed it
now this is this suggests that you might
be able to use a fully targeted imaging
agent to predict long before physical
symptoms emerge whether your drug is
working or not so you know just to see
if this might apply to other drugs we
looked at some biologics with the same
question in mind we looked at em
berliner NC a-- in the mouse model and
after three days both of them also
knocked down the inflammation in the
feet as is indicated by this full a
targeted radium imaging agent the
disease control's again shown in the
center and it doesn't show anything and
again if you look at the plots in this
paper that I think just appeared online
is this just appeared online you can
read about it there's no indication at
this early time point you know even
though later these biologics both had an
effect on at benefit in treating the
autoimmune disease we go on we decided
to look and see well maybe everything
shows up so we looked at a drug that
these that collagen-induced arthritis
and animals do not respond to him and
that's naproxen and indeed we didn't see
a response and the clinical data confirm
that then finally we did well we decided
after that would go to a number of
different autoimmune and inflammatory
diseases to see if it it were the case
and this is another one ulcerative
colitis and you can see the healthy
animal on the Left no uptake the
diseased animal in our ulcerative
colitis model shows significant uptake
and then when we treat that with just
standard drugs for treating ulcerative
colitis I met adenine sulfasalazine we
saw at four days right after starting
the treatment significant
reduction in uptake of the imaging agent
even though when you look at the
clinical score at this time point you
can't see a difference so again we pick
up and can predict the outcome long
before it's it's evident in the clinical
examination the same thing applies all
just real quickly since the time's
running out for a pulmonary fibrosis
which is a disease characterized by anti
inflammatory rm2 like macrophages and
again the standard therapies their work
and the results can predicted then we
thought it might be very important
finally oh in these for use in
predicting outcome when the clinical
outcome would not be evident for months
and months and months and this would be
an advocate treatments for heart disease
to look at the build-up for example
atherosclerosis and this is we looked at
on the right valsartan rosiglitazone
ramipril and said 'hey it flew past and
so forth and all of them showed what you
see under treatment very early a very
significant effect long before the
clinical differences were manifested so
just concluding I think there's some oh
I forgot I put in just a little bit here
on why not use large antibodies for all
of this it just turns out that I'll just
skip to the point that antibodies
penetrate tissues very very slowly take
several days for them to reach their
sites whereas small molecules here's
that here's a good curve showing in the
same animal in the same tumor the
penetration of a fully peg rhodamine
conjugates oh it's folic acid targeting
rhodamine but there's a large peg in
between and those are the first few dots
through the first 60 minutes there and
then at 60 minutes in the same animal we
add folate rhodamine with no peg in it
and immediately the tender saturates the
larger molecule simply doesn't penetrate
very fast and we find that to be a big
advantage for imaging so here are my
conclusion
good drugs that go to the wrong cells
cuts cause toxicity so targeting can
overcome that nonspecific drugs can be
targeted to pathologic cells with low
molecular weight homing my aunt's of the
sort that we've designed responding
patients can be selected with an imaging
agent targeted with the same ligand
targeting or homing ligands can be found
for many diseases i showed you can't sir
i showed you infectious diseases they
showed autoimmune inflammatory diseases
and then of the additional applications
can be found for these targeting ligands
and i spent a lot of time on the
fluorescence guided surgery but there
are a lot of others here's my lab the
group that has done all the work and I
give them all the credit because all I
did was sit in the office and answer
questions and then here are the names of
a lot of people i need to give credit to
they at other institutions that have
been very instrumental in the success of
this project so thank you very much for
your attention and I'm happy to answer
questions and I have a I'm not sure
where to get to this questions because
do i click on the question and answer
thank you dr. low for that informative
presentation our audience can submit
their questions by clicking on the human
a botany which we have found the green
tuning button for lower left of the
presentation window but try to get to as
many as we can you do have one question
already if any tissue which is normally
what has more folate receptor how can we
know that it is not and well I think we
have to rely on the fact that most of
the normal tissues that express folate
receptor express this receptor in an
inaccessible location where it wouldn't
be imaged with a fully targeted imaging
agent that is injected in the vein ferd
let me give an example of this there are
fully receptors on the apical surface of
alveolar epithelial cells in the lung
these receptors
our only on the surface of the cell
facing the air sacs so unless your blood
bleeds into the air sacs your foe lately
imaging agent will not access those
receptors and will not bind to them so
as you saw in the image of the beginning
a healthy individual that has neither
cancer nor an autoimmune or inflammatory
disease should show up take only in the
kidneys in this particular case the
folate receptor is also expressed on the
apical surface of an epithelial cell but
because folates are small enough to
filter in the year into the year enter
into the filtrate they can access this
receptor on the apical surface which is
the surface facing the urine and so
because of that that is one yep ethereal
surface that has fully receptors that
can be accessed and there are very few
others they're only in the lungs and
then there's one in the choroid plexus
of the brain that's on the wrong side of
the blood-brain barrier but other than
that we shouldn't see any update so if
you see uptake it should be at a site
other than the kidneys a chippie cancer
or an autoimmune or inflammatory lesion
any other question any other face yes we
didn't have another question is the
folate receptor always targeted or can
some other receptors be targeted as well
I'm with folate we only see the folate
receptor targeted now there aren't fully
receptors different isoforms one is
polite receptor alt and that's the one
that's expressed on cancer cells and on
a few of these epithelial cells and I
mentioned folate receptor beta that's
expressed on activated macrophages but
not resting on for pages or other cells
there is also fully receptor Delta
that's expressed on the open the egg and
it's also expressed on regulatory
t-cells but it doesn't bind folic acid
with any what physiologic affinity at
the binding constant is three orders of
magnitude weaker than the others the
by any constant for help and betas that
we don't target it it just doesn't have
a pion of affinity and we never see
fully receptor gamma so then we use
other ligands as i mentioned to target
other receptors we use dupa to target
the prostate specific membrane antigen
receptor and so forth so we've got like
ants for all sorts of different diseases
that target these diseases and we are
using them to deliver both imaging and
therapeutic agents okay okay do have
time for one more question dr. Lowell
would writing ligon targeted therapies
did the studies evaluate the ratio
between folate target imaging and
neutrophils segmentation I'm not sure
what what the questions about on the
Foley target the Foley targeted images
you know have varying degrees of tumor
to background ratio or or for our you
know inflamed lesion to background ratio
it depends on the abundance of the
cancer cells or the abundance of the
activated macrophages but where they are
highly abundant the tumor to background
ratio is very high and we don't see
uptake in neutrophils i'm not sure what
the neutrophils segmentation question is
about neutrophils do not have a
functional folate receptor okay it is
all the time we have for questions now I
would select ask dr. Lowe if he has any
final comments for our audience now I
app you have other questions you can go
ahead and email me them to me I i'll try
to answer them although i get it over
100 emails a day and i have our time
keeping up with them but certainly if
there are pressing questions be happy to
address them thank you for your
attention and if you have any
suggestions for good experiments i'd
love to have them
thank you dr. Lowe I would also like to
thank our sponsor today roche
diagnostics as a global leader in
healthcare verse diagnostics offers a
broad portfolio of tools that help
healthcare providers the early detection
prevention diagnosis and treatment of
diseases a molecular diagnostics verse
is driven by a vision of working with
laboratories like yours to improve the
medical value you offer in microbiology
infectious diseases oncology and
genomics we continue to meet unmet needs
through our investment in research
innovation and scientific excellence to
learn more please visit us diagnostics
volcom this presentation will be
available on demand six months from
today through March 2016 and you'll
receive an email from Lavery's alerting
you when that on-demand presentation is
available we would invite you to forward
that email to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
again for joining us thank you to our
sponsor roche diagnostics that's all for
today goodbye